known my name is Laura McDermott I'm
working with Kathy heidenreich and
Marvin Pritts and dr. Harold fan us on
this management soil management and
berry crops grant and I'm happy to have
you here I hope that there will be a few
other folks joining us here as we get
going I do want to i think probably most
of you have already taken the time to
fill out the ser demographics
questionnaire and the educator pretest
which is in the file box on the lower
right hand corner of your screen but if
this is your first time visiting us for
one of the webinars and you have not
done it please take a few moments either
right now or at the end of this
presentation to fill that out and send
that to Kathy heidenreich it's very
important for the grant and while we're
on that topic I might also remind folks
that we are in the final phase the last
three webinars today then March second
and then the final one will be on March
ninth and at that time we're going to
have a post-test of all the educators
hopefully we're going to have a really
good showing for that final webinar
because that's a very important
consideration and how effective the
webinars are for relaying educational
information that extension folks can use
out in the field with growers we also
want to remind those of you who have
been in attendance for a number of these
webinars that we are hopeful that you'll
take the opportunity to make the next
step so using all of the materials that
it will be available to you as
participants in this first portion of
the grant we'd like to have you take
those educational materials out into the
field and host some grower
grower workshops grower field days
whatever and then kind of report back to
us and kathy has some formats and if you
have any questions you can contact her
or her or myself about that but we'd
love you to start to get your head
around that and plan for something this
this growing season all right um before
we get going also I'd like to make sure
folks know a little bit about the
webinar I think most of you have done
this but you can type into the chat box
a long narrow box at the bottom in the
center that's where you enter your
comments and questions and I will try to
keep track of them please go ahead and
introduce yourself if you haven't done
that yet even though you may feel like
you do it every single time it's helpful
for the presenter to kind of get to know
where everyone's from additionally the
web links which is in the lower left
corner you can click on that and then
you can actually browse to that right
now or at the end we're going to go back
to the this kind of format at the very
end so they'll be there and they'll also
be accessible as the recorded webinar
alright today with this is the 10th in a
series of twelve berry crop nutrition
and soil management training webinars
and our speaker today is dr. Harold man
asks who's the professor and chair of
the Department of crop and soil sciences
at Cornell University and I will now
switch into that presentation mode dr.
Vanessa's current research and extension
interests are in precision management of
nitrogen soil health and space and time
statistics he teaches an undergraduate
course in soil management for
sustainability and a graduate course in
that space and time statistics he is
offer authored over a hundred refereed
publications and for books and advised
45 graduate students and I'm exhausted
for him so I'm really glad that he's
here hey Harold hello can you hear me
sounds good okay well thank you laura
and it's a pleasure to be joining this
group again i looked at my calendar and
it was almost exactly four months ago
when i did the the first webinar one of
the early ones on basic soil information
and cyril management principles and
since then we've discussed as a group at
least you know nutrient management and
soil health management and doing that
mostly from a production perspective
today we're going to be talking more
about some of the environmental impacts
and and how we can reduce that let's see
I'm having a little bit of a problem
there we go go into the next slide okay
the the outline for today and by the way
I had this put my picture up there it's
a slightly different picture than the
other one just to make it a little bit
more more personal for you but we'll
we'll start today with discussion of
environmental lost processes then
erosion and runoff prevention then we'll
talk about managing phosphorus and then
managing notch and do a summary and then
we'll go into the question and answer
session and I try to organize my slides
and my presentation in a way I think
that will allow you to take some
concepts that you can use with your
stakeholders that will help you I think
in your educational programs so we'll
start looking at environmental losses
the primary ones that we might be
concerned about with with Barry
production is sediment nitrogen
phosphorus and pesticides and i should
say say a front that that most most of
the the berry production is done in a
way that that is is relatively
sustainable has relatively little
environmental impact say compared to
corn production which is more
large-scale it's an annual crop a lot of
these
oils are being tilt on an annual basis
and so when we compare that to to most
berry crops we're dealing with
perennials and and not as much tillage
and and typically not as much nutrient
inputs either so so often the
environmental impact maybe maybe smaller
yet we we do need to be concerned about
that and we need to take that serious so
in the picture here you see the
basically the basic hydrologic cycle and
and the main point is that these
environmental losses occur when we have
a lot of water in the system or that
water of course comes mostly as
precipitation some cases a little bit as
as irrigation but but really it's the
it's the extreme precipitation events
when we get you know an inch to or even
more we that's when we tend to have the
the problems and so an important concept
to consider is is what happens at the
precipitation when it reaches the land
surface and it can basically go in two
directions it can either infiltrate or
the water that does not infiltrate then
runs off and creates all kinds of
problems because it will take with it
these contaminants like sediment
nitrogen and phosphorous and if it takes
sediment then we refer to that as as
erosion and that may readily of course
reach streams or other water bodies like
lakes and nesto ares and that is in
general very undesirable but if we're
lucky that all the water infiltrates and
then it's being held in the in the soil
and i like to refer to the soil as a
sponge and and the soil holds on to that
water and then makes it available to the
plants through evapotranspiration if
there is excess water in the soil then
it will percolate further down either to
deeper groundwater or maybe shallow
groundwater that might eventually reach
a stream so those are the processes and
so is chemicals go with the percolator
order then we refer to that as as
leaching so if we think about these lost
pathways the the ones that we're
concerned about our run off we're mostly
with phosphorous to a lesser extent with
nitrogen and then maybe with pesticides
for erosion which means that runoff that
takes with it all the sediments and the
sediment in turn may have a lot of
phosphorous with it or some nitrogen and
pesticides and so all of these
contaminants are concerned when we have
erosion corrosion is a really bad thing
when we have leaching we're concerned
mostly with nitrates and pesticides
phosphorus basically doesn't lead to
except in some very unusual
circumstances and then we finally we
have a concern about gaseous losses and
that is typically not directly driven by
by water but indirectly especially when
it comes to nitrous oxide which is
generated when the soil becomes an
aerobic and so when it's saturated and
there's no air in the soil and then the
nitrogen is transformed from sainnites
rate to nitrous oxide and of course this
is a big concern because it's a serious
greenhouse gas it's 300 times more
potent then then carbon dioxide and we
may have some gaseous losses of
pesticides which is really unrelated to
to water typically that has to do with
the properties of the pesticide itself
and I'm not going to discuss pesticides
in detail today it's a little bit beyond
the scope of what we wanted to talk
about so we're going to focus on
sediment nitrogen and phosphorus so the
environmental loss potential in in
general is is affected by a number of
factors so one obviously the weather we
discussed that if you have a lot of
intensive rainfall you have higher
potential for runoff and erosion and
excess water also generates leaching
secondarily we have these inherent soil
properties like texture and organic
matter
which also affects you know basically
where the water goes and what it takes
with it and then we'll discuss that in a
little bit more detail thirdly soil
health and we've talked about that
optional Beck mentioned that in the
previous webinars so if we build up our
soil and we make it healthy would say
good aggregation then we can reduce the
environmental loss potential
significantly and then finally perhaps
the what we might call the more
real-time Cyril management practices
such as whether we cultivate the soil
which may expose it to the elements
whether we have sort of cover like mulch
whether we traffic the soil causing
compaction and those kind of things and
then of course last not least is is you
know how much fertilizer we apply
organic or inorganic fertilizer and
where we where we place it because of in
principle the more fertilizer or other
organic materials that we put out there
the higher the potential that we have
losses so what we'll come back to these
individually but first let's let's
discuss you know the the basic inherent
properties of soils and how that affects
potential environmental impacts you know
texture or the distribution of particle
sizes in terms of sand silt and clay is
is probably most fundamental property
and you know we're all familiar with the
the textural triangle and at the
provides the basis for a lot of these
environmental laws considerations I like
to talk to my students or the
stakeholders as as the sole particles
and the texture of the soil so defining
what we might call the house the basic
structure of the soil and I like to use
the analogy of a house in that you know
the you have the structure of the house
which is the walls and the roof and the
basement and all that and that's the
most visible part of the of a house and
and it's the particles for the soil
that's what you see
the most interesting part however is
what happens in the spaces between the
soil particles or with the house analogy
what happens in the rooms because that's
where all the processes take place
that's where the organisms are that's
where the life is and that's where the
interesting things happen so in soils
there's there's bacteria fungi all kinds
of organisms that live in the pores and
that's also where all the important
processes of water and air movement
occur so I'd like to have people farmers
and students to to sink in soil and
terms sir I'm not just in terms of the
particles but have them think in terms
of the spaces between the particles so
when we think about a sandy soil then
most of those pores are relatively large
although in general terms are still
talking about less than two millimeters
in most cases but bye bye Sol standards
those are very large pores and those
pores will lose their water very quickly
because the capillary force that we see
when large pores is relatively weak
conversely when we talk about clay soils
we mostly have small pores the capillary
force is really really strong and they
retain the water very tightly okay but
if we have a clay soil that actually has
good aggregation then we may have a few
larger pores that are between the
aggregates or then we maybe have both
small and large pores so this is an
example of an aggregate that has the the
range of pores so it has the larger
pores and those facilitate in filtration
and drainage aeration and routing
because they lose the water very quickly
because of the week capillary force the
small pores they retain the water very
well and so they facilitate both water
and and nutrient retention so when we're
concerned for example about leaching we
like to see
these nutrients being retained in in the
soil so I have a question for you here
talks you two questions first one is
which soil has a higher Legion potential
a sand silt or a clay and the second
question is which soil has a higher
runoff and denitrification potential the
gaseous losses of nitrogen just send the
silt or the clay and I'm sure you all
got this question just right it's the
course the sand that has the highest
leaching potential because it's mostly
large pores doesn't retain the water and
the nutrients very well so they easily
washed out with the percolating water
and for to its of course the clay that
has a higher runoff potential mostly
small pores are not very good
infiltration capacity and because it is
mostly small pores the aeration can
often become a problem when you get a
lot of water and so you have higher
denitrification so I am sure you all got
those answers correct so when we go back
to our textual triangle again so we're
talking about the more sandy soils like
ass and the loamy sand sandy loam model
large pores I leaching potential when we
have higher clay contents we tend to
have higher runoff and denitrification
potential now let's look at things a
little bit more in in a landscape
perspective and we often use the term
hydrologically sensitive areas for four
parts of the landscape that have a high
potential for pollutant losses and in
some cases we are concerned about runoff
surface losses in other cases it's
leaching and subsurface recharge losses
so when we where do we in the landscape
have high run off losses in floodplains
and this is kind of an interesting
scenario because most floodplains
actually tend to have relatively coarse
textured soils like gravel so kind of
sandy's
else that that you might say well they
have high infiltration capacity but
because they are located near stream
basically if you get heavy rains you get
flooding then basically everything goes
so you havin a lot of nutrients on the
soil or soil is very poorly protected
then a lot of that gets lost and in the
Northeast we certainly experienced that
this year with with a hurricane and and
and a follow up in parts of the
Northeast with with it and some other
heavy rainfall events so similarly areas
that are adjacent to flowing or standing
water bodies are hydrologically
sensitive primarily because they tend to
be wetter areas in the landscape and
because they are close to these water
bodies so there's very little buffer a
very low opportunity to filter out some
of these these contaminants areas with
low infiltration capacity are a concern
maybe because the soil has become
compacted or sometimes it's even when
it's adjacent to say a road or or some
other compacted area where the runoff
that comes off that area then goes on to
a field and may reduce runoff and
erosion on the field and then areas
generally there are saturated that are
already wet have a high runoff potential
as well okay so let's then think about
about the leaching and subsurface
recharge areas the ones that we're
mostly concerned about our are areas
that are close to either wells or
Springs these are typically areas that
have very permeable soils and when
you're very close to these water sources
that people use for drinking water we
need to be extra careful and so that's
those those are sensitive areas and in
general areas with very permeable soils
are also of concern so we have to think
a little bit in terms of of the root of
the location that that a field or farm
might have in the landscape and so you
know going back to my earlier
presentation from a few months ago we
talked about soil survey reports and
how useful that information is whether
you're using the the paper copies with
the traditional maps or whether you go
to the online version the circled web
soil survey which is just a fantastic
tool it provides you with information on
basic soil properties on suitability for
use and in this case also the
environmental lost potential so the soil
survey can be a very good sort of first
source of information to to start
thinking about these problems and how to
address them okay so let's let's look at
at one of the concerns that we have and
that's that's erosion and there's two
aspects of erosion that are undesirable
one it removes the good soil it it
removes the soil right from the surface
it it's typically the soil that's the
highest in organic matter and it's the
most desirable and and what at least
behind typically is the kind of the
gravelly material the course fragments
that don't get washed away as easily by
the runoff water so with many years of
erosion we basically lose our best soil
the other aspect of course is that this
soil ends up somewhere else as a
sediment and this pollutes water
resources what it streams or eventually
going into lakes or estuaries or rivers
and this discovers aquatic habitat it
makes it less suitable for drinking
water or even navigation so both of
these aspects of course are highly
undesirable and erosion really remains a
large problem here in the in the united
states we still have a lot of concerns
about it so is the number of factors
that affect that Searle type and slope
so typically soils that have a high run
off potential also have higher erosion
potential steeper slopes of course are
of greater concern soil health can be a
big factor as well if we if we basically
built a soil
but say good aggregation good plant
rooting that you know pumps the water
out very well we are going to be
reducing the erosion potential and then
also surface management you know whether
we keep the soil covered or whether it's
exposed using tillett's or you know
herba sites or something like that that
can greatly influence the erosion
potential so here's a quick illustration
of that that that shows these these four
graphs in different stages of the
development of erosion so on the top
left we see a raindrop and a raindrop
actually has a as a certain amount of
energy basically from its mass and its
velocity it then reaches the land
surface and that is basically what
initially it creates the concern when
the soil is dry is relatively hard and
initially resilient and can absorb the
energy of that raindrop but as the soil
starts to Wed up it becomes soft and it
becomes weaker and the raindrop energy
is cannot be absorbed quite as well to
the point where that surface layer
becomes very soft and very susceptible
to the energy of the raindrop which may
cost then the aggregates or the soil
itself to be smashed and and dispersed
and you see that here and in the picture
you see a very soft soil and you can
actually see the impact of the addition
of the individual raindrops that
basically destroy the soil you start to
see water accumulating at the surface
and if this is on even even a modest
slope you start to initiate run off and
then erosion now one thing we could do
is is of course we could try to cover
that soil with say mulch or you know
some other type of say organic compound
maybe even even some compost
and and that that material that service
cover can then absorb the energy of the
raindrops so instead of it falling
directly onto the soil it's being
absorbed by say the mulch and this
greatly greatly reduces the erosion
potential so one of the best things we
can do to reduce erosion is to have the
soil covered and that's depicted here in
this you know rather famous graph that
shows the relative erosion or soil loss
from a zero to a hundred percent and the
percentage service residue so if we have
bare soil we have losses at a hundred
percent but we see then a fairly rapid
decrease in the erosion losses what even
with modest modest amounts of service
residue so if we have about thirty
percent service residue we reduce the
erosion losses by about sixty percent
from a hundred 240 and then if we
increase the amount of service residue
in the end we end up with relatively low
erosion losses so one of the best things
we can do in terms of reducing of ocean
losses is to cover the soil and the good
thing is this also has a lot of benefits
in terms of building healthy soils to
reduce the effects of extreme water and
temperature conditions at the surface to
promote biological activities so it to
some extent it is a no-brainer to put
mulch or other materials on the surface
so in terms of erosion and runoff then
what are sort of the main strategies you
know in summary avoid fields that are
prone to flooding or have high runoff
potential if at all possible keep the
soil coverage with mulch or residue or
even compost built and maintained soil
health especially aggregation to
increase infiltration capacity and
reduce the runoff potential and then use
grass alleyways preferably along the
contour so
pictures here this this shows of course
the surface mulch is also soil that has
received compost and so it's in really
good shape kind of like the soul that
you see here this is a picture that
shows these alleyways that in the winter
time we'll have a a rye cover crop and
this can then be mowed onto the rose
this in this case we have grapes here in
South Africa but we can use that then as
a mulch to go into the into the rose of
course you can bring in external sources
of mulch as well and then the bottom
picture shows you a grass alleyway
especially if it's along the contour
that's good because it will infiltrate
water quite well it will filter out any
sediment that might come from the rose
if they are unprotected so those are
some good management approaches that are
really not difficult to implement and in
fact are being implemented by most berry
growers okay so let's continue on and
now talk about nutrients in the early
seminar we discussed in the nine what we
call macro elements the elements that
plants need in relatively large
quantities so the the carbon oxygen and
hydrogen are are available of plentiful
in the natural world and it's primarily
the nation and the phosphorus that are
the ones that are are applied in large
quantities but are also of environmental
concerns so that's what we'll be
focusing on so this this pictograph
shows the difference in Los pathways
between nitrogen here on the top versus
phosphorous on the bottom and although
they are both nutrients they behave very
differently in the soil and they have
very different impacts so we'll discuss
those in some more detail so nitrogen
can be in the soil in in both organic or
inorganic form as nitrate and ammonium
most of the nation we hope will be taken
up by the crop I mean that's
that's our objective and that's that
promotes good growth it may run off or
erode but typically with nitrogen those
are that's a relatively insignificant
loss pathway it's mostly the leaching
and the volatilization and
denitrification that are the primary
lost pathways and so those are the ones
that we are are concerned about their
both initiated by very wet soil
conditions now phosphorus on the other
hand can be in the soil also inorganic
and mineral form again the desired
pathway is crop uptake leaching is only
a problem in some very rare cases where
does just excessive amounts use the
excessive amounts of phosphorus in the
soil where we're dealing with very sandy
soil with shallow water tables but in
most cases it's really the runoff in the
erosion that's a primary concern with
phosphorus so let's look at each of
these in a little bit more detail
starting with phosphorus so here's a
pictograph again so it's primarily the
runoff and the erosion that's of concern
here's a picture from a lake in Canada
with with a barrier in between it shows
the area that received phosphorus inputs
and then the area that did not most of
the freshwater lakes in the in the in
North America or phosphorus limited and
it actually takes relatively little
phosphorus to induce eutrophication or
algae growth or even aquatic vegetation
and this is to some extent the natural
process but it gets accelerated by
phosphorous that comes from from farms
again berry farms are probably not a
huge contributor but but they could
contribute with poor management
practices well one thing we need to keep
in mind because erosion and runoff are
the primary processes for phosphorus
losses then you know from that of course
it's a logical conclusion to say
practices that reduce runoff
Roshan also reduced Foster's losses and
so you know having surface mulch
improving infiltration capacity through
good soil health management etc these
are all practices that also reduce
phosphorous losses but there's another
dimension to that and that's basically
the the the accumulation of phosphorus
in in the soil if we end up with lots
and lots of phosphorus in the soil then
we increase the loss potential and
that's an additional concern so if we
just think about phosphorus levels in
terms of a a soil test level which we of
course measure on a regular basis we
know that if the soil test levels are
very low that we have reductions in
yield and that there is sort of a point
where you say well there's sufficient
phosphorus in the soil for good crop
production we have sort of an optimum
range but then if we really get too much
phosphorus in the soil then then we have
excess and this excess phosphorus is
much more susceptible to losses to run
off in erosion and that's that's a
concern so the above graph is basically
kind of a hypothetical case on the
bottom here I'm showing you some some
real data of relative yields this is for
corn and alfalfa and grass but it shows
you that in this case for for a Morgan
extractable p that if you're sort of in
this range of four to six that's sort of
where the cutoff is between going from
below optimum to to optimum and so you
don't have any guilt increase beyond
that but in at some point in time you
starting to get into excess of levels
and even though this the the response to
syrupy levels is often quite somewhat
variable and low precision there is a
really strong agreement that these
levels
that there is a certain level where you
really have an optimum amount of
phosphorus in the soil not deficient and
not excessive and so I just wanted to
show you as a comparison because many of
you may be using different extractants
you're here in Northeast we mostly use
modified Morgan or which is just like
Morgan certainly in terms of phosphorus
some of you may be using Olson or Bray
or or maelich one or Malik three and and
this here shows the different ranges
because the extractants are are slightly
different and they and end up with
extracting a little bit more a little
bit less phosphorus depending on the
method and so they each have their
ranges in terms of low optimum high and
very high and it's under the very high
where we get to be concerned about
excessive phosphorus losses and so we
would like to be able to to prevent that
from happening we don't want to have too
much phosphorus in the soil that will
possibly cause environmental concerns
now in most cases if if a farmer
regularly soil tests and and it's very
careful about how much they apply you
don't really see any problems with that
the cases where you do see that
occurring is typically with a lot of
organic inputs so we see that with
manure especially say on a dairy farm
that has a lot of excess nutrients then
that builds up the phosphorus or we also
see it sometimes with you know repeated
compost applications sometimes with with
even with organic farms because both
manure and compost are not as well
balanced in terms of nitrogen and
phosphorus that is that you typically
apply too much phosphorus for what the
crop needs if you apply the right amount
of nitrogen
do this year after year and then you
start to build up your phosphorus levels
so these are some some real soil samples
of cases where there's been an
increasing amount of organic phosphorus
applied and these are then for Malik or
from margan the the the soil test levels
and you can see that they really build
up and they are really highly excessive
which is really what we would like to
like to prevent from happening so if you
have a situation like that when you have
too much phosphorus in the soil then you
need to to make sure that you that you
change the diet you might say of the
soil where you add your nitrogen in a
different way perhaps you can do that by
adding say clover residues or alfalfa or
or a if you're not an organic grower
then perhaps you can simply apply some
nitrogen fertilizer and a smaller amount
of compost so that that you can start
reducing those phosphorus levels in the
soil so and we account for that in the
Cornell soil health test in in terms of
the scoring curve that we use for
phosphorus analysis and that was
discussed in the previous webinars
bye-bye optional Beck so the scoring
curve basically the idea is that we
interpret and actually measured value of
a soil health indicator in this case
phosphorus and we interpret that in turn
on a scale from basically zero to a
hundred so if we have very low
phosphorus levels then we give it a very
low score and as the phosphorus level
increase then we increase the score as
well so and this is then where we around
four to six where we reach the optimum
level but then we start to down score it
basically when we start to reach
excessive levels of phosphorus so it is
important that that you try to keep your
phosphorus level sort of in this optimum
rain
so sort of between about four or five
and about 20 and that you don't want to
go into excessive levels so to summarize
the phosphorus management what are the
main strategies well the first four that
we see here are the same as we use for
runoff and erosion prevention okay
because if you don't get any runoff then
you don't have any any problems with
losses so the same one the void for high
flooding locations keep the soil covered
maintain soil health and maintain grass
alleyways but now we have this fifth
consideration is monitor the soil
phosphorus levels and try to avoid
excessive phosphorus so these five
management strategies are very effective
in reducing p losses ok so we've talked
about erosion we've talked about
phosphorous now let's talk about
nitrogen an addition is a very kind of
complex element in the soil and both in
terms of how it behaves in the soil but
also in terms of the larger
considerations around managing and
there's a there's a number of concerns
that we have about Rob nitrogen these
days one is the is the high energy
consumption that's associated with the
haber-bosch process that basically is
the industrial process that takes
historic nitrogen to reactive nitrogen
it requires a lot of natural gas a lot
of energy and it generates a lot of
carbon dioxide secondly we have a
persisting concern about groundwater
nitrate levels we haven't really seen a
lot of improvements in general over the
past couple of decades in nitrate levels
which is the results of excess of
nitrogen applications especially in
these more sandy areas or even urban
areas the other one that we're concerned
about is is the losses of nitrogen into
streams and rivers and then into
estuaries and this map here on the
bottom shows the the about 300 locations
around
world whether a lot of concerns with
high levels of nitrogen in s wherries
causing hypoxia or low oxygen levels and
fish kills and all that one area that's
really quite well known is northwestern
Europe where there's a lot of nitrogen
use a lot of intensive dairying this is
the original area of where the dairy
systems were developed and then of
course on in North America the area
along the east coast starting sort of
with southern New England going down to
Florida and then of course along the
Gulf Coast where we have probably the
largest problem as a result of all the
nation that comes out of the Mississippi
River Basin primarily associated with
with corn production but these are often
very important as to where ease like for
example the Peconic Bay on Long Island
where there's a lot of concerns even
from horticultural farms about trying to
reduce nitrogen losses so the fourth
area of concern is is greenhouse gases
primarily nitrous oxide n2o which is the
result of denitrification and again
Barry production may not be a huge
contributor but agriculture overall has
a very large footprint in terms of of
greenhouse gas impact actually very
disproportionate to the share of the
gross domestic product about seven to
eight percent of greenhouse gases are
associated with agriculture and most of
that is a nitrous oxide losses because
nitrous oxide is about three hundred
times more potent and carbon dioxide and
and so we need to try to reduce that
through prudent and judicious nitrogen
management so let's go to our pictograph
hear about the bud nitrogen again crop
uptake is desirable we may have a lower
runoff and erosion but most of the
losses will be leaching or
denitrification if we have you know more
sandy gravelly soil most of it will be
through leaching and this is as nitrate
because nitrate is negatively charged
and
negatively charged as well so therefore
it very easily percolates down and
washes down with with with the water in
the soil the volatilization and
denitrification losses are primarily n 2
which is the nation guys that's also in
the atmosphere which is not at all a
concern because seventy eight percent of
the atmosphere is already dianetics and
gas but it's the nitrous oxide that's
the primary concern now when we have a
denitrification event from say a heavy
rain we may actually lose quite a bit of
nitrogen we may easily use 30 40 pounds
of nitrogen per acre either through
dinner and nitrification or two
releasing with a heavy rainfall event of
say an inch and a half at the other
component that i should mention this
volatilization of ammonia that is also a
concern primarily with acidification so
the the nitrogen cycle of course is is
relatively complex and I won't go into
detail about that it's I think the main
point is that there's a lot of these
these transformations that occur in the
soil that are in part driven by all
these sources of nitrogen that come you
know from agriculture and what it moves
from one state to the other state that
maybe become subject to leaching or D
identification and gaseous losses and
and all that so I'm going to simplify
that by using this graph here so this
first source the sources of soil
management one of them is we get a
little bit of nitrogen from the
atmosphere typically about maybe six or
eight pounds per acre it's free nitrogen
basically but a relatively small
quantity in most field conditions we get
a significant amount of the nitrogen
from the mineralization or basically the
decomposition of soil organic matter
that may be native in the soil other
organic materials that may have been
applied like manure or
compost or residues and then color crops
especially legume honest cover crops
like clover or alfalfa and these all get
get decomposed and the organic nitrogen
is mineralized to inorganic nitrogen
primarily as a result of you know
biologically biological processes which
are in turn affected by temperature the
other source of nitrogen of course is is
mineral nitrogen which is which is
fertilizer it could be ammonia type
fertilizers it could be a nitrates type
fertilizers so we have all these
different sources of variation that are
associated with nation availability and
that makes it actually a little bit more
difficult to manage nitrogen we
different soil types have different
sources if you're looking at the
Midwestern soil they have a lot of
organic matter and it's very deep and
they have have good structure they
provide a lot more nitrogen than say a a
soil in the Northeast that's very sandy
and a postural type type soil that has
relatively little organic matter and
nitrogen mineralization of course the
amount of organic matter in the soil
affects the nitrogen availability and we
have seen soils you'll build up organic
matter when they're very well managed or
loose organic matter when they are say
have a history of intensive tillett's or
erosion of course how much you add in
addition in terms of organic amendments
like compost and manure whether you have
cover crops and what types of cover
crops look you minutes versus grass
cover crops for example soil and crop
management you know how intensively you
till and things like that whether you
have drainage or not and if you have
poor drainage then you may get a lot of
losses especially if nitrogen
temperature is a factor because a lot of
the mineralization is temperature
mediated because it's a biological
process and then of
last but not least precipitation because
of a soil that's a very dry will not
mineralize nitrogen or so let's to wet
one mineralized antigen and all these
things in a way interact in very complex
ways and that's what makes it very
difficult to precisely predict how much
nitrogen needs to be added to your soil
to adequately feed the crop but there
are really some some guidelines that we
have if we understand the system a
little bit better so this is this
picture here shows the the nice
mineralization as part of the incubation
time this is from an earlier paper by
Cass Minh and months and what it serves
you hear that the most of the nation
comes from the surface soil this is the
0 to 18 centimeters which is about 0 to
7 inches and we see the increasing
amount of nitrogen being mineralized
over incubation time up to a hundred
days this is the square root it's a
hundred days and then we see that as we
go deeper into the soil less and less
medicine is mineralized and becomes
available so it's a surface soil that's
the most important that provides the
majority of the nitrogen so in the field
and this is a laboratory study but in
the field nitrogen release will be
affected by weather conditions like
temperature so organic minor content
soil types etc so let's now consider the
the losses so we looked at the sources
of N and these are the primary losses
one of them is is ammonia volatilization
and that can be the result of the
application of ammonia type fertilizers
especially if they're left right at the
sorrel service so that they can follada
lice and you can reduce that by
basically incorporating it or injecting
it into the soil also manure can often
have ammonia fertilization so if you
apply menteur even some compost and you
leave it on the surface and you might
lose some of that through volatilization
we talked a little bit about runoff and
erosion tends to be not that big of a
problem the primary losses of nation
from runoff and erosion is when you
leave the organic or inorganic serve
fertilizer on the surface and it gets
gets removed in a heavy rainfall event
the other losses the major losses are
denitrification and nitrate leaching as
we as we mentioned again the primary
objective of course remains getting the
United into the crop so again it's
management so health precipitation and
temperature that are all critical
factors in terms of the losses it's
always if you get a lot of water you get
a lot of precipitation that creates most
of the problems that can create the
leaching denitrification is affected by
both precipitation and by temperature
because it's an indirect loss and it's a
biologically mediated loss so if you
have actually very cold soil you may
have quite a bit of nation in that soil
but you won't get much denitrification
losses because the soil is cold and the
biological activity is low so when you
really do see a lot of denitrification
losses is is sort of you know a little
bit further into the growing season when
the soil has become warm and then you've
got a lot of rain and you can lose
easily 30 to 50 pounds per acre in a
heavy rainfall event and so in a way
you'd like to be able to account for
that so when we go back to our basic
properties in terms of pore sizes we can
think of the lost potential again in
terms of large pores good aeration so it
reduces denitrification losses small
pores reduces leaching losses and
ideally you have some of those because
that provides a well balanced soil which
you tend to get from a well aggregated
soil
another concern related to nation is is
poor internal drainage so if you have
barriers deep in the soil and you have
water tables that are at you know
relatively shallow depths that promotes
of course denitrification losses you can
remediate that through insulation of
subsurface drain lines and of course
race beds also reduces susceptibility to
imperfect drainage so it's an it's a
component that's often forgotten but you
know poor drainage creates problems
especially with nitrogen losses but even
with runoff and erosion and phosphorous
losses because souls that have poor
drainage tend to have higher potential
for runoff because the soul remains wet
and saturated so what are the main
strategies then for reducing nitrogen
losses do not over apply in addition by
accounting for all sources of nitrogen
inputs like this organic matter compost
manure fertilizer etc ideally provide an
addition in multiple applications and
account for weather factors we're
actually on the scientific front making
a lot of progress in this area we now
have four field corn and sweet corn we
have a tool that we developed the adapt
and tool that allows for for prediction
of how much nitrogen he needs using
model simulations accounting for all
these weather effects that we discussed
but I think for for even for very
producers where we may not have a tool
like that you can have basic rules rules
of thumb if you have say a very wet
spring then you probably lost some of
that nitrogen through denitrification
and leaching depending on your soil type
and you may need to make up for that and
apply a little bit of extra night it
shouldn't say in your second application
but if you have a relatively dry spring
you may want to do the opposite because
you didn't have any losses so you don't
want to over apply so you can
again even you know without really using
sophisticated sophisticated methods you
can make some adjustments to your
nitrogen based on the weather conditions
next one build and maintain soil health
aggregation organic matter etc that
especially on the medium defined texture
soils will help with aeration and with
water and nutrient retention source Oh
health management again it's important
not only from a production perspective
but also in terms of reducing the
environmental losses and then finally as
i mentioned facilitate good drainage so
i wanted to show you these two soil
health reports and to look at that sort
of in the context of the environmental
lost potential so these are two very
similar soils but one had a history of
no manure inputs and the other one had a
history with manure inputs and even
though these soils inherently are very
similar they're medium textured soils
you can see the aggregate stability
without manure was fifty three percent
but it became 78% with multiple minori
inputs so we have actually make the soil
more made the soil more desirable by a
line for a better aeration reduced
reduced potential for denitrification
losses the available water capacity went
from point 1 to point 2 6 so we've
increased the ability of the soil to
retain the nutrients as well so we've
both reduced the anta fication losses in
principle and we've reduced the leaching
losses because we have better water and
nutrient retention also notice that the
organic matter content without manure
was 2.6 and whitman or it's been built
up to over six percent so that has a lot
of benefits similar with the act of
carbon and the potentially mineralized
relation that's an indicator of the
amount of nation that we can expect from
mineralization that one's from about 6
to about 23 and so
the soil on the right of course can
provide a lot more nitrogen from natural
sources than the one on the left so all
in all the one on the right with the
manure in puts is of higher health
higher quality and and presumably
reduced environmental input impacts okay
so this is then my last slide where I
want to put everything together that
we've discussed in the past hour and I
think first and foremost most very
production systems have low
environmental impacts from nutrients and
sediments and part of that is because
they that is inherent with the
production practice and the fact that
you're using a perennial plant so
there's not a lot of tillage going on
there's not a very large amounts of
nutrients that normally get get applied
and so it's not as big of a concern as
perhaps you know corn production or some
of these other major crops as size
characteristics like soil type location
etc can affect potential losses like for
example when you're on a floodplain or
whether you have very clay soils and you
know naturally soils that have higher
runoff and erosion potential in addition
to that a true management we can
increase or decrease the potential for
these losses leasing or runoff and
erosion so when we build up the soil
through good soil health management we
can increase productivity and reduce the
environmental impact so it's a win-win
situation and then in addition we need
to make sure that we don't put too many
nutrients out there that we that we are
careful about what we apply so prudent
nutrient management can prevent most of
these losses and with that I will hand
it over or back to Laura to our
moderator and be happy to entertain
questions Thank You Harold I know that
tom has a question about whether or not
the soil health test showed second to
the last slide was with manure from a
corn silage field and then I actually
had some questions about that same slide
so I don't know would it be possible to
go back to that yes we can go back to
that yes I mean the the soil on the on
the right there they were both soils
that were in corn production and the one
on the on the left was primarily corn
for grain and the one on the right was
part of a dairy system so it was corn
silage with manure inputs okay hopefully
that answers Tom's question and my
question may be a little bit off topic
from the very example but i'm i'm just
wondering about the root health rating I
struggle a little bit with the soil
health test trying to understand what's
happening and definitely I can see the
positive impact that manure has but why
is the soy the root health rating lower
do you think I would have to go back to
all the details about the particular
farm which I don't really have with me
it probably has to do with the fact that
the the field that was that received in
manure inputs also had rotations with
alfalfa and we used the bean bioassay
for to look at the so let me just put
the air or there whether you say bean
bioassay so which is also a legume so we
may have increased the root disease
pressure a little bit simply by the
rotation it's typically the rotation and
the types of crops that are part of the
rotation that are the primary concern
but keep in mind that we use a for the
root health rating we use a sensitive
indicator crop which is which is snap
bean basically that and that's what we
use in comparison now if you're if
you're not growing snap beans of course
then you need to understand that you
know your crop might have slightly
different susceptibility but we selected
that's not being because you know it is
a the best indicator typically that you
can use for vegetable production
okay great thank you it looks like
there's a couple of other folks typing
and maybe we can get some other
questions here Kathy wonders how long
does the effect of a heavy downpour
persist in terms of nitrogen losses to
soil is it an hour so after the event or
a day or more okay good question that
Kathy yes so if you it takes a little
bit longer it takes several days what
when we have a more finer textured soils
like a lot like Absalom down to a clay
loam you know when we get a lot of
rainfall this early comes saturated and
if it doesn't drain well then the soil
remains saturated and then it takes
about two days in fact we've done a lot
of research on that and take a lot of
measurements it takes about 48 to 72
hours then for these anaerobic
conditions to occur and that's when you
get most of the losses so it's not
immediate because the soil needs to
remain saturated for about two days for
the e ates or the redox potential to go
down and that's when you get most of the
losses and similarly with leasing losses
it takes about a day or so day or two
for the water to move down through the
soil and then to wash out most of the
nitrogen I hope that answers your
question okay great and then there is
another question from Glenn he's
wondering if the additional traffic from
manure applications increased the
surface and subsurface hardness I think
he's referring to that very slide that
right right yes yeah absolutely and we
we do see this a lot on dairy farms
where these soil health indicators are
all looking great you know it's all in
the green and the ratings are very high
in the 90s and then we see that the
hardness is typically the source very
heart and so the score is very low on
that and that's because
on these fields that receive manure a
lot of the memo gets applied with very
heavy manure spreaders oftentimes under
very marginal conditions you know the
farmers want to get the manure onto the
land early in the season because they
want to get to planting and so a lot of
these these soils actually show a lot of
compaction problems yeah that's very
observant of you and then again from
Glenn he's wondering if there's
relationships between temperature and
precipitation have been condensed into
interpretive rules by which one could
apply observed and forecasted weather
data in to adapt and recommendations
let's see now I need to any to look at
that really quickly myself okay I've
been condensed into interpretive focus
yes so if you're interested in in adopt
and I would encourage you to disco to
our website if you just Google adapt and
you will get there but the the adopt end
system is it basically it involves a
dynamic simulation model which which
simulates soil and crop processes like
water movement through the soil and
nitrogen transformation and also
accesses a high-resolution weather
database that was developed here at the
Northeast climate center right here in
the same building where I am now
bradfield hall and so the adapt end tool
basically simulates all these conditions
for the early part of the growing season
it estimates the nitrogen additions
through mineralization and and all that
and it estimates the losses and then it
comes up with a recommendation for site
dressing in this case corn in principle
you know we could also get into other
crops so but that's that's what it does
it's it's very dynamic and it takes all
of those temperature and precipitation
factors into account and it does it in a
kind of a daily time step okay and then
there's a question from Tom he's
wondering if there's any new research on
remediating compaction mechanical
ripping or bio drilling with a
deep-rooted crop like forage radish or
alfalfa
well yeah Tommy I mean those are of
course some of the some of the things
that more recently have been developed I
i think the the bio drilling is very
exciting this is for those who you're
not familiar with it ray while at the
University of Maryland has done a lot of
work on that often in collaboration with
Steve graph was a very progressive
farmer in southeastern Pennsylvania the
idea is to use you know radishes
especially you can plant them in in
September typically for most of the the
areas that we're concerned of and and
they established very strong and fat
roots I mean they're radishes and that
basically kind of loosens up the soil we
call it bio drilling and yes if you have
compaction the best way to address that
is is to find some way to D compact and
it could be through bio drilling it
could also be simply through a out some
limit and targeted tillage and then to
try to prevent that from happening
through you know Cyril health management
practices and organic matter additions
and and all that the soil becomes more
resilient to to compaction and more
resistant if you have you know better
aggregation and better air exchange and
all those kind of things yes so those
are some of the areas you know we we've
talked in the past about you know using
frost tillage as well that you know
wouldn't be that appropriate for very
production but it's a you know you
basically till the soil weather when it
has a very shallow frozen surface and
that can be you know if there's been a
lot of compassion that occurred in the
fall that can be a way to alleviate the
compaction that way you do that at you
no particular time windows during the
winter ok and then kathy has two related
questions she's wondering if there is
then a short term and or long-term
residual effect on nitrogen availability
after the heavy rain event she's going
back to that question initially
she asked and then if nitrogen is
applied after the heavy rain event is it
more susceptible to loss if another vet
event follows there's not necessarily a
residual effect that I'm aware of and so
if you have such a heavy rainfall event
you you lose a certain amount of the
nitrogen you know so if most information
that's in the soil is in the nitrate
form so the most reactive form then you
will lose a significant amount of that
with with a big rainfall event either
through leaching or through
denitrification and then it's gone and
you won't get it back basically then
there's no necessarily not a residual
effect per se other than that the soil
is at that point in time quite wet so if
you get another rainfall event you know
say four days later and the soil is
already wet then of course you can go
into another leaching or denitrification
event but if you apply the nation you
know subsequent to these events and not
immediately but say you know a week
later or something like that then in
principle that's not being impacted by
what happened to the to the previous
nitrogen and that is a way to make up
for some of these losses all right I
think does anyone else have any
questions for dr. Venice all right
they're pretty quiet I'll just move into
the exit screen I want to thank dr.
Harrell vanness for being with us today
and I want to remind the the group that
remains that the speaker for the next
webinar is dr. wolinski Santos who is
the assistant professor of horticulture
at the University of Florida and the
topic will be fertigation in hydroponics
of strawberries he'll talk about new
diagnostic tools and precision precision
agriculture for Barry crops again if you
have not completed the demographics
questionnaire or the pretest please take
an opportunity to do that right now
and I want to thank all of you for
joining us and we will see you the next
webinar is March second so we have a
couple of weeks break and then we'll be
back on march second and March ninth
finishing again with dr. van ness and
thank you
you